[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur TV 78 pour le 7
8 c'est votre émission pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu de l'actualité des idées
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce jeudi 23 mars
malgré l'adoption définitive de la
réforme des retraites la contestation ne
s'arrête pas une neuvième journée de
mobilisation se tenait ce jeudi à
l'appel de l'Inter syndical pour faire
reculer le gouvernement une
manifestation a pris le départ ce matin
de la gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'agglomération des habitants viennent
de lancer un collectif contre la
retraite à 64 ans c'est une maladie
génétique rare la myopathie de Duchêne
touche environ 2500 personnes en France
mais la recherche contre la pathologie
est peut-être sur le point d'avancer une
entreprise du territoire Sky
thérapeutique vient d'obtenir un avis
favorable pour le lancement d'un premier
essai clinique et nous en parlons avec
notre invité Louise Garcia directeur de
recherche au CNRS et co-fondateur de
l'entreprise qui a été thérapeutique
enfin comme tous les jeudis la sélection
de nos idées de sortie pour le week-end
il y en aura pour tous les goûts un
événement hommage à Johnny Hallyday à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux le retour du
fest-noz attrapes ou encore elle le
retour et la réouverture du domaine de
Dampierre en Yvelines pour ça 5e saison
il y aura des invités pour évoquer tous
ces sujets en plateau parce qu'elle te
va bonsoir directeur général du domaine
de Dampierre-en-Yvelines j-2 avant la
réouverture pour cette cinquième saison
du domaine quel est votre état d'esprit
juste avant cette ouverture tout à fait
serein après des gros travaux hivernaux
sur le château on est capable de le
montrer maintenant restaurer les
derniers coups de râteaux dans les
allées font que on attend maintenant le
public tout est prêt tout est prêt à vos
côtés il y a Christian Étienne bonsoir
président de l'association du cirque
celtique cyzabel alors vous allez
organiser une nouvelle édition du fest
noz c'est un événement bien sûr festif
très attendu du côté de trap ce sera à
samedi à 20h du côté de la Meurice même
question est-ce que est-ce que tout est
prêt
prépare la salle samedi dans la journée
et samedi soir on accueille tous les
participants pour nous présenter en
quelques mots votre association une
association assez vieille sur le
territoire elle a fait ses 50 ans l'an
passé je crois que c'est la plus
ancienne association culturelle de la
Ville-Ouest de Quentin-en-Yvelines et
donc 50 ans l'an passé 51e anniversaire
qui sera fêté pour le fest-noz qui aura
lieu ce weekend à la memorise à Trappes
on en parle tout à l'heure bonsoir
Régine raleche bonsoir de la rédaction
de TV 78 avec vous dans un instant les
informations du jour on va parler
forcément de cette 9e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et de réformes des retraites
il en sera question justement avec notre
autre invité Clément verrai bonsoir vous
êtes membre du collectif de 50 ans de
nuit un collectif qui a été lancé à 50
ans en Yvelines justement contre la
retraite à 64 ans il y a environ une
cinquantaine d'habitants qui composent
aujourd'hui ce collectif vous mobilisez
chaque mercredi soir juste à côté de la
gare de 50 ans en Yvelines au niveau de
la diagonale à l'entrée de cette
diagonale est-ce que vous étiez mobilisé
aussi aujourd'hui pour cette grève 9e
journée j'étais mobilisé ce matin pas
cet après-midi parce que il fallait que
je puisse venir ici mais j'étais
mobiliser ce matin justement la
manifestation qui a eu ce matin entre la
gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et le
Medef des Yvelines on aura l'occasion de
parler de votre engagement au sein de ce
collectif présenté ce collectif tout à
l'heure dans cette émission également
focus sur le mobile sport 78 c'est un
camion itinérant qui sillonne les routes
du territoire sont ambition de rendre le
sport accessible partout dans les
Yvelines et puis à suivre également
notre rubrique conseil mode avec la
styliste Mélissa sebir ce soir vous
saurez tout sur les pièces indémodables
de votre garde-robe voici le programme
programme chargé ce soir pour le 7 8
juste avant de le dérouler un petit coup
d'œil par la météo de demain
[Musique]
même condition météo même température
demain matin sur l'ensemble du
territoire yvelinois avec quelques
éclaircies fera 11 degrés dans le Nord
et le Sud du département dans
l'après-midi le temps viral l'orage
prévoyait quelques averses côté
température il fera 13 degrés à
Rambouillet 14 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdan et ce vendredi 24
mars elle nous fêterons les Catherines
enfants d'émission vous donnera les
prévisions météo pour ce week-end dans
les Yvelines avec une petite surprise on
vous en dit pas plus le point à présent
sur les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines
on commence cette actualité du jour
Régine avec un point un point sur cette
9e journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites oui après
l'intervention du président Emmanuel
Macron les opposants à la réforme des
retraites continues de ce mobiliser du
côté des transports le trafic était très
perturbé aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines
notamment sur la ligne C où il fallait
prévoir un train sur trois du côté des
raffineries il fallait compter 14 % des
stations dans le département qui était
en pénurie d'au moins un carburant dont
4% en pénurie totale et du côté de
l'éducation 25% des enseignants se sont
déclarés grévistes dans les écoles
primaires et les collèges et ils étaient
20% dans les lycées selon les chiffres
de l'académie de Versailles au-delà de
la mobilisation parisienne mobilisation
également dans les Yvelines qui s'est
tenu ce matin c'était ce matin à
l'initiative de la CGT des opposants à
la réforme des retraites ont manifesté
ils étaient d'ailleurs 200 à la gare de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à 10 heures et
se entendu au siège du Medef à
Guyancourt on écoute Bernard guilleret
un membre de l'Union fédérale Sud
industrie cette réforme des retraites
c'est une fausse qui prétexte un
problème financier qui va se reproduire
dans 10 ans faut pas se leurrer le vrai
problème c'est blocage des salaires le
vrai problème c'est que l'inégalité
entre les hommes et les femmes si on
leur attrapait c'est les heures
supplémentaires qui sont totalement
détaxés c'est les entreprises qui payent
pas leur impôts et Paypal leur
cotisations sociales et c'est pour ça
que nous on est dans la rue aujourd'hui
et en parlant de manifestations la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites va peut-être obliger les
autorités à modifier le programme de la
venue du roi d'Angleterre à Paris comme
vous le savez déjà le roi d'Angleterre
devait dîner au château de Versailles ce
lundi 27 mars mais le contexte politique
a bouleversé les choses le dîner
pourrait finalement se tenir à l'Elysée
Charles III nouveau roi d'Angleterre au
menu aussi de l'actualité alors ça va
arriver ce weekend c'est une édition
2023 du week-end du Sidaction c'est ce
weekend tout à fait ce sera du 24 au 26
mars à l'écran vous pouvez d'ailleurs
voir le nouveau spot d'appel au don et
comme chaque année trois jours de
mobilisation de sensibilisation et de
collecte son prévu auprès du grand
public et si vous aussi vous souhaitez
soutenir la recherche vous pouvez
appeler le 110 ou faire un don
directement sur le site de sidaction.org
on termine avec une information insolite
elle concerne un député des Yvelines et
ce député c'est car le livre il est allé
rendre visite au pape avec variété Club
de France accompagné d'Aix gloire du
football le député yvelinois a remis au
pape François 1er un maillot de l'équipe
siglée du numéro 10 le variété ensuite
affronté ce mercredi une équipe du Saint
Siège et l'a emporté sur le score de 8 à
2 merci beaucoup Régine pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si
aussi si vous aussi je vais y arriver
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un
fait ou d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir et n'hésitez pas à le dire sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
on continue ses actualités par cette
actualité dont on parlait régime bien
sûr c'est aujourd'hui c'était
aujourd'hui la neuvième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et on le disait en début
d'édition des 50 chinois ont créé leur
collectif contre ces retraites un
concept retraite à 64 ans Clément verra
est avec nous vous êtes membre je le
disais de ce collectif vous êtes
habitant vous de la commune de
Guyancourt comment c'est fait cette
création de collectif comment est né
l'idée de de voir rassembler au sein
d'un collectif je le disais tout à
l'heure une cinquantaine d'habitants qui
composent aujourd'hui ce collectif il y
a une assemblée générale le 3 mars qui a
regroupé des gens qui venaient du milieu
associatif qui venait de milieux
saint-guytose deux milieux syndicaux
pardon de milieu politique et qui se
sont dit il faut qu'on arrive à faire
quelque chose localement faut qu'on
arrive à créer quelque chose localement
qui permettent aux gens de s'exprimer
aussi que ce soit pas seulement à Paris
que ça se passe mais de montrer que bah
oui dans les Yvelines il y a des gens
qui qui sont aussi mobilisés contre la
réforme des retraites et qui appelle
d'autres citoyens se mobiliser également
du coup en complément des syndicats
c'est ça aussi le but de la mobilisation
là ce sont des habitants directement qui
se mobilisent ce sont des citoyens et
citoyennes qui sont effectivement
mobilisés sur le territoire
Saint-Quentin et ses environs donc pas
forcément syndiquer pas forcément si
politisés dans dans des assemblées
locales des conseils municipaux il y a
de tout il y a encore une fois des gens
qui viennent d'horizon syndicaux
d'horizon la société d'horizon politique
et qui qui se sont juste retrouvés
autour de ça de dire cette réforme des
retraites ça n'est pas possible donc il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose on voyait
quelques images de votre mobilisation
vous rassemblez chaque mercredi soir au
niveau de la diagonale à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux on n'est pas loin
de la gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
mais pourquoi vous êtes contre cette
réforme des retraites on le rappelle un
adopté tout récemment il y a eu le rejet
des deux motions de censure à
l'Assemblée nationale adoption
définitive de ce texte de loi cette
semaine alors ça va dépendre des gens
les gens qui sont qui sont issus de
milieux syndicaux vont pas avoir
seulement avoir les mêmes raisons que
les gens qui viennent qui sont issus
plus ou d'un milieu politique ce qui est
mon cas donc chacun a ses raisons
finalement dans ce collectif le seul
truc qu'on sait c'est qu'on est tous
contre il y a des gens qui disent
64 ans j'y arriverai pas l'ouverture des
droits 62 ans ça permettait quand même
de partir quand le travail devenait
insupportable côté syndicat il y a des
gens qui disent ben voilà c'est simple
on nous vole les deux meilleures années
de de notre retraite pour les deux pires
années de travail pour les gens qui ont
des métiers pénibles les éboueurs les
égoutiers c'est quand même extrêmement
difficile d'entendre ce genre de
discours et puis quand on vient du
milieu politique on se dit aussi c'est
quand même on a tout fait pour que cette
réforme ne se passe pas dans des
conditions normales on a accéléré la
procédure à l'Assemblée nationale pour
que les parlementaires dont le métier de
débattre ne puisse pas débattre
sereinement finalement est-ce que le
débat n'a pas été confisqué aussi par
l'opposition qui a déposé une dizaine de
milliers d'amendements et ce qui a fait
qu'on n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au enfin en
tout cas les députés n'ont pas pu aller
jusqu'à l'article 7 de la réforme qui
prévoyait ce décalage à 64 ans alors le
truc d'abord du gouvernement qui dit qui
dit à des gens à des parlementaires dont
le métier quand même de discuter de
trouver des compromis dans une assemblée
qui pour la lune des premières fois de
l'histoire de la Cinquième République
est assez représentatif de l'ensemble de
la population leur dit ben non vous avez
50 jours pour débattre 175 heures de
débat à l'Assemblée nationale c'est rien
on est vraiment sur l'épaisseur du trait
peut-être pas mais on est sur quelque
chose d'assez d'assez ténu et dans ce
que vous commencez à avancer le
l'utilisation du 49-3 on le rappelle
l'article de la Constitution qui permet
de faire passer un vote sans un texte de
loi sans vote qu'est-ce que comment vous
avez réagi à cette nouvelle utilisation
alors
en fait c'est mal réagi parce que
finalement il y a beaucoup de gens qui
voulaient aller au vote et je pense que
même du côté des députés de la majorité
présidentielle il y a beaucoup de gens
qui voulaient aller au vote qui
voulaient aller s'exprimer là-dessus
dire oui non ou même simplement exprimer
par l'obtention le fait que ça ne leur
convenait pas qu'il n'était pas contre
mais que ça ne leur convenait pas donc
voilà on est on est assez dérouté de ne
pas avoir eu de vote finalement la
première ministre a reconnu elle-même
que ça s'est joué à quelques voix près
et que finalement parce que le compte
n'y était pas parce qu'il n'était pas
sûr que ça allait passer ils ont décidé
de d'utiliser un 49-3 qui a été vécu par
la plupart des députés en tout cas ceux
que j'ai pu ce que j'ai pu comme une
commune brutalité aussi de se dire mince
qu'est ce qui se passe tout d'un coup on
nous confisque le droit de donner notre
dernier mot finalement en tant que
Parlement sur ce texte est-ce que vous
avez fait partie avec les mauvaises et
10 millions de Français qui ont regardé
hier l'interview de d'Emmanuel Macron
c'était sur TF1 et France 2 oui j'en ai
fait partie alors qu'est-ce que vous en
avez pensé on le rappelle alors c'était
la première fois qu'il s'exprimait le
président de la République depuis
l'adoption de cette réforme on le
rappelle après les le rejet des
différentes motions de censure pour
contrer ce recours du gouvernement au
49-3 il s'est montré déterminé manuel
Macron à faire appliquer la réforme
avant la fin de l'année c'est d'y prêt à
endosser l'impopularité de la réforme
des retraites et la réaffirmer sa
confiance envers la première ministre et
Elisabeth borne qu'est-ce que vous en
avez pensé
on attendait une réaction du président
de la République ça faisait un petit
moment que il était étonnamment muet sur
le sujet donc je pense qu'on était
beaucoup à attendre sa réaction on
s'attendait plutôt à un discours
apaisant et fédérateur au final apaisant
ça n'a pas tellement été fédérateur oui
mais plutôt contre lui donc de mon point
de vue c'est un échec c'est à dire qu'il
a il a effectivement la seule chose
qu'il a fait c'est énervé encore plus
les gens qu'il avait déjà énervé alors
maintenant que la réforme a été adoptée
le seul recours en tout cas c'est ce qui
a avancé aussi par les différents
groupes d'opposition c'est cet examen
par le Conseil constitutionnel qui doit
valider examiner le texte et le valider
les oppositions espèrent que les sages
censureront le texte en partie pour non
respect de la Constitution c'est
également aujourd'hui votre eSport c'est
c'est le dernier espoir qui qui vous
reste alors c'est pas le dernier espoir
ce que c'est le dernier recours c'est le
dernier recours légal et constitutionnel
il y a d'autres recours aujourd'hui les
syndicats l'intersyndicales appellent à
renouveler ses mouvements de grève ce
n'est pas le seul moyen effectivement
que ce texte ne passe pas il peut aussi
être retiré par le Président de la
République il peut aussi être non
promulgué par le Président de la
République c'est des choses qui se sont
déjà vues par le passé effectivement une
des pistes c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel malheureusement quand on
est engagé contre cette réforme des
retraites on ne peut pas juste se
permettre d'attendre le bon vouloir du
Conseil constitutionnel dont il n'est
absolument pas garanti qu'ils sont sur
rat tout ou partie la mobilisation on va
continuer ensuite pour essayer de faire
reculer le gouvernement je pense que
l'objectif aujourd'hui de la
mobilisation c'est de faire recouvrir
reculer le gouvernement avant que cette
notion de censure ne passe tout bien sûr
quel type d'action était menant on
parlait de cette mobilisation que qui a
lieu tous les mercredis soir est-ce que
vous avez prévu d'autres actions par la
suite dans les prochains jours alors il
y a d'autres actions prévues donc déjà
de toute façon tous les mercredis soirs
on est effectivement la diagonale de 17h
à 19h avec des prises de parole en
public avec des gens qui maintenant
amènent des guitares et qui chantent
enfin voilà c'est très très bon enfant
on a prévu effectivement au moins ça et
puis derrière on encourage les gens on
explique comment se mettre en grève on
encourage les gens à donner des caisses
de grève voilà on organise des actions
un peu au jour le jour c'est justement
sur les actions de la diagonale de 17h à
19h qu'on décide qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire pour le reste de la semaine
dernière viennent à votre rencontre pour
pour parler de ce texte alors pour
parler de ce texte
et leur expliquer ce qui va changer
concrètement aussi pour eux alors on
essaye de nous vous expliquer
concrètement ce qui va passer on affiche
des cas des cas concrets en disant voilà
vous êtes né en 1978 vous avez fait tant
d'années d'études ben voilà avant la
retraite vous pourriez partir à telle
date maintenant vous serez obligé de
partir à telle date avec tel des cotes
avec voilà on essaye de vraiment
expliquer concrètement ce que ça va
représenter pour les habitants on a
aussi des gens qui viennent simplement
exprimer le fait que ils sont contents
qu'il y ait d'autres gens qui se
mobilisent quoi une dame qui a pris la
parole c'était assez émouvant mercredi
qui disait je suis très déprimé depuis
une semaine parce que je vois que ça
n'avance pas je vois que le gouvernement
est sourd et de voir autant de gens
comme ça motiver qui se mobilisent bah
ça donne du baume au coeur merci Clément
d'être venu parler de ce sujet en
plateau je rappelle membre de ce
collectif d'habitants à collectif contre
la réforme des retraites qui a été
lancée dans l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines Véronique
Jérôme maître de conférence en économie
à Paris c'est clair revient justement
sur le conflit des retraites entre le
vote de la loi et la colère de la rue
pour elle le plus dur est à venir et ce
même en cas d'apaisement le
mécontentement pour être se payer lors
des prochaines élections intermédiaires
[Musique]
à trop jouer à sa passe ou ça casse ça
finit par passer mais passant casse
drôle de réforme qui rassemble une
majorité conséquente d'opposants et
autant de convaincus qu'elle passerait
et après s'interroge-t-on désormais le
prétexte de la légitimation de la loi
par le vote était un argument suffisant
pour baisser les armes à tout loin de la
part de syndicats légitimistes et
progressiste comme la CFDT le passage du
49.3 l'a incité à suivre désormais des
plus radicaux comme la CGT vers une
intensification de la pression
conflictuelle force est de constater que
du bras de fer engagé des coûts sont
apparus coup direct nés des amendements
qui réduisent d'autant les économies
attendues de la réforme coût indirecte
les pertes de salaire de la part des
grévistes coûts d'opportunités comme ce
manque à gagner né de la nécessité de
compenser des dépenses imprévues et puis
il y a aussi cette perte pour l'économie
globale sauf rattrapage ultérieure
qui dominera dans le jugement des
Français deux hypothèses sont possibles
il y a d'une part une reconnaissance à
moins que ce ne soit une déception tout
dépendra aussi de la trace nesique plus
ou moins forte des ressentis à laquelle
peut s'ajouter l'apparition d'un
possible effet d'asymétrie du blâme ou
ce qui déplaît l'emporte sur ce qui
plaît mais finalement la période la plus
difficile n'est peut-être pas celle de
la lutte mais bien celle de l'après qui
démarre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on va parler de santé à présent dans le
7 8 avec cette annonce fait il y a un
mois la NSM l'Agence nationale de la
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé à donner un avis favorable à
l'entreprise Sky thérapeutique c'est ce
pour le lancement d'une première étude
clinique sur la myopathie de Duchenne on
en parle avec notre nouvelle invité
c'est Louis Garcia bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes directeur de recherche au CNRS
conseillé scientifique de ce qui a été
thérapeutique je vais être même le
co-fondateur de cette entreprise basée à
50 ans en Yvelines et qui est d'ailleurs
même hébergé au sein de l'UFR santé
Simone Veil de l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on le précise
une entreprise qui a été créée en 2015
qu'est-ce que Sky thérapeutique en
quelques mots parce qu'il a été rappelé
que c'est un peu une aventure au départ
c'est une aventure elle a été fondée par
des parents des parents de patients de
malades atteint de la myopathie du chêne
par des chercheurs des cliniciens
également tout ce petit monde s'est
retrouvé ici à l'UFR santé à l'occasion
de la création de notre unité de
recherche en 79 Inserm
UVSQ et puis dans dans la foulé on a
créé cette société avec pour objectif de
créer des médicaments parce que la
recherche on en fait très bien à
l'université mais l'université n'est pas
destinée c'est pas sa mission de
fabriquer du médicament pour ça il
fallait une entité un peu spécifique de
type biotech et c'est ce qui a été
thérapeutique qui a pris ce flambeau
avec la volonté de l'ancré sur le
territoire c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle sky on a la bannière Skywest
juste derrière sur Skype
le médicament était conçu fabriqué
développé
produit en partie et sera testé sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin aussi
puisque le lycée clinique aura lieu à
l'hôpital de Garches qui dépend de l'UFR
santé donc on reste sur sur ce
territoire on va parler de cet essai
dans un instant juste sur la myopathie
du chêne précisée qu'elle touche 150 à
200 garçons nouveau-nés en France
environ 2500 personnes en sont affectées
par cette maladie génétique rare
qu'est-ce que la myopathie de Duchêne
qu'elles en sont les causes et quelles
conséquences ça entraîne sur sur le
malade alors c'est une maladie
emblématique vous avez dit le nombre en
fait c'est un garçon sur 3500 3000 selon
les chiffres 50 pas tout à fait à la
naissance d'accord donc ça veut dire
compte tenu du nombre de naissances en
France on divise par deux filles garçons
ça fait à peu près deux nouveaux cas par
semaine donc c'est un peu comme au loto
sachant que tout le monde ne joue pas
mais il y a que les femmes qui ont des
enfants donc c'est une maladie quand
même rare mais c'est parmi les maladies
rares c'est la plus fréquente d'accord
et elle touche les enfants dès l'âge de
2-3 ans et c'est une maladie évolutive
donc c'est elle est emblématique pour ça
parce que à partir de deux trois ans les
enfants des difficultés à marcher ils
perdent ambulation vers l'âge de 8-10
ans en général parfois 12 ans puis après
ça s'aggrave c'est une maladie on
connaît bien le quand j'ai commencé
d'ailleurs c'était une maladie
strictement pédiatrique aujourd'hui on a
de jeunes adultes on a de jeunes gens
maintenant de la maladie donc il y a eu
des progrès dans la prise en charge mais
ça reste quand même des des cas avec des
des handicaps très très lourds et la
maladie connue maintenant depuis un
siècle et demi c'est du chêne de
Boulogne qui avait identifié au milieu
du 19e mais on n'a toujours pas de
médicaments
des sac cliniques beaucoup de promesses
on espère que nous ce sera une réussite
mais pour le moment on ne peut que
promettre les causes on les connaît de
la maladie génétiques c'est des
mutations dans un gène particulier qui
est localisé sur le chromosomix le gène
de la dystrophie ce qu'on a donné le nom
de la maladie à ce gène et c'est en fait
c'est une protéine qui joue un peu le
rôle comme d'un amortisseur d'accord
entre la membrane et l'intérieur de la
fibre musculaire et donc ça amortisse ça
fait des tas de transition de signaux il
y a d'autres fonctions mais on imagine
très bien que son rôle de d'amortisseur
quand cette protéine n'est pas là
l'amortisseur n'est pas là ça crée une
partout ça se déchire ça s'abîme et en
fait les garçons ont simplement en
marchant en jouant détruisent leurs
muscles et donc peut-être on espère une
bonne nouvelle dans la lutte contre
cette maladie puisque je le disais ce
qui a été thérapeutique a reçu la vie
favorable de la NSM pour son étude
clinique avance 1 cela consiste à
administrer chez l'homme le composé vous
parliez de ce médicament Sky 51
qu'est-ce que ce composé qu'est-ce que
vous souhaitez observer justement avec
cette étude qu'est-ce que vous allez
observer alors ce composé un c'est un
peu singulier le rationnel thérapeutique
derrière est connu depuis une vingtaine
d'années c'est le ce qu'on appelle le
saut d'exemple on a beaucoup parlé sur
les plateaux télé tous les ans au mois
de décembre ça c'est ce qui est
particulier là singulier là c'est que
c'est une nouvelle chimie c'est la
première fois que cette chimie va on va
exposer des êtres humains à cette chimie
les tricycloé DNA un peu de l'ADN un peu
bricolé et donc pour ça on appelle ça un
first and human first and man et ça
c'est une première c'est une première
aussi parce qu'en France on est des
essais cliniques on a des essais
cliniques sur cette myopathie mais
souvent c'est des phases 2 ou des phase
3 c'est des phases d'extension là c'est
un premier médicament qui est synthétisé
sur nos territoires et s'ils sont un
territoire avec une technologie de notre
territoire ça c'est le fruit de ça
et thérapeutique c'est et voilà d'un
collectif je vais pas tout seul on est
il y a 20 ans de personnes qui
travaillent sur ce projet et voilà c'est
une histoire collective alors ce
médicament c'est ce qu'on appelle un
oligonucléotide ça ressemble à de l'ADN
c'est tout petit c'est 15 du pilotis de
15 bases le génome il y a des milliards
de base 15 bases et on les injecte en
systémique c'est-à-dire dans un vaisseau
sanguin ça va aller un peu partout
ça va accrocher le gène malade au fur et
à mesure qu'il est transcrit en ARN pour
faire la protéine manquante on peut pas
le faire parce qu'il est muté génétique
ce petit truc va s'accrocher à un
endroit bien spécifique on a calculé un
peu comme un anticorps comme un vaccin
et réparer localement provoquer une
réparation et le garçon parce que seul
les garçons sont en train de cette
maladie parce que c'est sur le
chromosomique pourront produire une
protéine qu'on dit semi-fonctionnelle
c'est pas la protéine normale elle est
quand même fonctionnelle et on espère
que ça va marcher et l'idéal c'est
d'arrêter la progression de la maladie
pour les plus jeunes qui ne rentrent pas
dans la maladie et on va dire pour les
plus grands les plus âgés ben en tout
cas les stabilisés et avoir une
amélioration on verra on verra de
calordre elle est on peut rien remettre
pour le moment mais de toute façon
régime justement pour cette essais
clinique combien de patients allez-vous
inclure dans cette et ses clinique et
comment est-ce que vous allez les
sélectionner
aussi le recrutement de passion
donc c'est de la première étape la phase
1 donc on va se focaliser sur la
sécurité avant tout donc ça va être une
progression avec une escalade de dose et
on prend une corde relativement petite
une douzaine de patients 12 patients
adultes enfant quel que soit l'état ce
qui compte c'est d'être malade avec
cette maladie et d'être éligible à ce
médicament parce que c'est un peu un
médicament à la carte c'est un peu comme
un vaccin on a un vaccin contre le covid
un vaccin contre la grippe c'est deux
vaccins mais ça vaccine pas contre les
mêmes choses sky51 Sky c'est nous qui le
faisons c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
Sky 51 c'est contre l'exon 51 de la
dystrophie il y aura un exonc 16 un
exemple 53 par la suite mais c'est des
c'est de la médecine personnalisée en
fait donc tous les patients ne sont pas
concernés malheureusement par ce
médicament seul 10 à 15% des patients
avec des mutations compatibles avec
notre médicament
et combien de temps va durer cet essai
alors la phase 1 va durer pour chaque
passion à peu près 3 mois une escalade
de dos celui 15 jours et puis ensuite on
demandera une prolongation en phase 2A
après autorisation par la NSM pour la si
tout se passe bien évidemment ou là ça
durera encore 6 mois donc l'un dans
l'autre
l'essai pour chaque passion durant un an
donc ça veut dire que si c'est concluant
on pourrait le voir sur le marché dans
combien de temps c'est plus compliqué
parce que il faut ensuite une phase de B
une phase 3 etc il y a peut-être si ça
marche si c'est spectaculaire on peut
espérer que ce soit avant si c'est moins
spectaculaire ça prend dans le temps que
ça prend fond du temps mais nous notre
objectif parce qu'encore une fois je
l'ai dit au début
la société est pilotée c'est la volonté
de parents
l'objectif c'est pas simplement de
vendre c'est surtout de proposer aux
malades quelque chose qui fonctionne
avec soit bientôt les ré et qui soit
efficace et on a le temps pour nous dans
le sens où on ne s'arrêtera pas sur un
échec c'est-à-dire si jamais on voit des
problèmes on reculera un peu on
arrangera et on reviendra donc c'est pas
c'est pas un aller simple et ça marche
ça marche pas merci en tout cas d'être
venu en parler sur ce plateau Luis
Garcia de cette avis favorable et donc
laissez clinique qui va débuter pour Sky
thérapeutique autour de cette maladie de
Duchenne je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche au scénariste
co-fondateur de cette entreprise Sky
thérapeutique merci d'avoir été merci
beaucoup focus à présent dans le 7 8 sur
cette initiative le comité départemental
du sport en milieu rural des Yvelines se
mobilise pour que le sport devienne de
plus en plus accessible dans le
département pour cela un camion
itinérant a été mis en circulation à son
bord un éducateur sportif et des
dizaines d'activités le reportage avec
Céline Charles
sportif son lieu de travail c'est ce
camion le mobile sport depuis plusieurs
semaines il sillonne les routes du
département
des ballons
du matériel d'athlétisme on a aussi du
matériel de raquette des sports
collectifs ça c'est ce qu'on appelle du
flag rugby donc c'est du rugby
accessible à tout le monde et en fait la
différence aujourd'hui c'est que il y a
pas de placage on attrape des petits
bandeaux qui sont accrochés à la
ceinture le sport partout et pour tous
c'est ce que souhaite le comité
départemental du sport en milieu rural
des Yvelines à l'origine du mobile sport
en mettant en circulation ce camion
itinérant son objectif et d'amener
l'activité physique et sportive dans les
territoires qui n'ont pas d'équipements
de structure ou encore d'encadrement le
but c'est d'aller là-bas d'amener le
matériel et de proposer avec la personne
qui conduit le camion qui est diplômé le
sport on n'est pas là pour faire de la
concurrence à qui que ce soit on est
simplement là vraiment pour pallier à un
manque qui a été
identifié et pouvoir permettre à tout le
monde en fait de trouver le juste milieu
et pouvoir intervenir alors avec
différents à différents moments de la
journée
j'espère il est important pour pour la
santé dans un premier temps mais pas que
pour la santé il est aussi important
pour l'esprit et pouvoir s'aérer aller
dans différents endroits serrer l'esprit
c'est ça régénère aussi aussi notre
corps en lui-même mairie association
école comité d'entreprise ou encore
particulier le mobile sport s'adresse à
un large public il propose une
cinquantaine d'activités adaptables pour
les enfants adultes seniors et personne
en situation de handicap on répond à une
demande on évalue si vraiment il y a
qu'est-ce qu'il manquer réellement
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin comment on
peut travailler ensemble et puis après
le jour J bah c'est parti quoi on a des
prix qui sont attractifs enfin on n'est
pas on est totalement différent on n'est
pas une entreprise en fait on n'est pas
là pour faire du chiffre on est là
vraiment pour rendre service aux gens et
c'est pour ça que on veut rendre le
sport accessible à tous et le fait de se
déplacer leur permettre déjà de faire du
sport 30000 euros de matériels ont été
investis le mobile sport et financé par
une dizaine de partenaires dont le
département aujourd'hui il se déplaçait
essentiellement dans le sud des Yvelines
allez à présent dans ce 7 8 c'est
l'heure de sortir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
avec les retours en plateau de Pascal
Teva on va parler avec vous de la
réouverture du domaine de
Dampierre-en-Yvelines Christian Étienne
également avec nous pour parler du
fest-noz de trap c'est ce samedi mais
aussi Céline Charles qui est elle
revenue alors les parvenues elle est
venue même en plateau de la rédaction de
TV 78 vous avez sélectionné pour noter
les spectateurs des idées de sortie
au-delà du domaine de Dampierre et du
fest-noz de Trappes on parle de Johnny
Hallyday notamment ce soir les fans de
Johnny vont être ravis de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et le fan club
officiel de Johnny Hallyday ce sont
donnés pour rendre hommage au chanteur
exposition et concerts sont au programme
et je vous proposerai aussi des concerts
et un spectacle
dans un instant alors l'une des sorties
incontournables du week-end à côté c'est
du côté de la vallée de Chevreuse le
domaine de Dampierre-en-Yvelines va
rouvrir ses portes pour une cinquième
saison et ce après environ 4 mois de
mise en sommeil hivernale Pascal tevard
on sait alors tout le temps s'est mis en
sommeil c'est aussi une période propice
pour faire des travaux on vous avait
reçu sur ce plateau pour parler de la
fin des travaux euh et la fin de ce
chantier de restauration du clos et du
couvert du château là le chantier
continue aussi à Dampierre il y a
d'autres travaux encore ça n'arrête pas
ça continue il faut quand même préciser
que c'est plus gros chantier d'Europe en
mathématonie sur un domaine privé sur un
château comme celui-ci qui est destiné à
trouver au public donc moi j'avais
tendance à dire c'était le plus gros
chantier de France et on m'a dit mais
non c'est l'Europe et donc on finit une
aventure extraordinaire à Dampierre et
évidemment l'hiver c'est propice pour
faire les chantiers mais on va continuer
même si on ouvre au public à partir de
samedi lundi et en semaine donc du coup
il y a le chantier mais qui est
complètement isolé du public puisque on
a tous sécurisé
émis en valeur ce qui a été réalisé par
les ouvriers cet hiver le domaine de
dompierre-en-yvelines on le rappelle
bijoux du 17e siècle
œuvre de Jules Ardon Mansart pour le
château André Le Nôtre pour les jardins
et le but depuis le rachat par Francky
Mulliez c'est de réveiller cette belle
endormie alors on parle même de de
belles endormi au masculin puisqu'on
parle du domaine de Dampierre c'est ça
le but aujourd'hui exactement on mène
vraiment cette politique avec les
propriét faire pour faire connaître à
nouveau dans pierre dans pierre était un
monument qui a eu connu ces heures de
gloire jusque dans les années 80 et puis
ça s'est endormi dans les depuis 40 ans
et donc Franck immobilier était là pour
redonner un nouvel élan à ce domaine à
ce château avec tous ces travaux qu'ils
mène à terme j'espère dans deux ans
venir et vous dire ça y est on ouvre le
château pour rentrer dans le château on
pourra rentrer dans le château mais
peut-être que une surprise durant la
programmation pourra rentrer cette année
dans le château un jour c'est je pense
en bonne voie pour que ça puisse se
réaliser et mais surtout c'est faire
connaître on est aux portes de
Saint-Quentin on est à 2 km à vol
d'oiseau et les gens le connaissent
peut-être pas donc du coup notre but est
bien c'est que les Yvelinois et les 5
continents évidemment mais les Yvelinois
viennent découvrir ce havre de paix au
cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse parce que
quand on est autour du château dans les
jardins on oublie en fait qu'on est aux
portes de l'accès d'agglomération c'est
sa force c'est son cadre
ça promet de belles balades en famille
autour de cette pièce d'eau justement la
pièce le jardin la pièce d'eau toute
différent parcours avec des jeux
d'énigmes qu'on a fait pour les enfants
dans les bosquets donner envie au public
de d'aller plus loin qu'autour de cette
pièce d'où et de redécouvrir cette ce
patrimoine de jardin patrimoine
architectural et puis cette biodiversité
puisque malgré tout et bien c'est aussi
la biodiversité qui s'est développé
parce que quand j'ai 40 ans où il s'est
peu passé de choses et bien au contraire
c'était une réservoir de biodiversité
qui s'est développé et donc le public et
bien apprécie d'être en contact avec
tous ces oiseaux tous ces animaux qui
sont voilà dans un état où les espaces
sont tellement vaste qu'on peut les
approcher sans les déranger vous
connaissez le domaine de l'Empire en
Yvelines j'y suis allé avec mon
association faire un email un mariage
donc le cadre voilà le cadre fermé le
cadre est excellent autour du plateau
vous êtes déjà allé sur place je n'y
suis jamais allé mais je pense que ce
sera l'occasion vous êtes un très bon
vendeur
c'est vrai donc cette cinquième saison
qui s'ouvre et à chaque nouvelle saison
il y a des nouveautés cette année quels
sont les principales nouveautés alors là
fort avec le printemps puisque le
printemps c'est le premier avril la
chasse aux poissons d'avril puisque le
premier abri c'est un samedi au salon la
chasse aux œufs de Pâques avant la
chasse aux œufs de Pâques et là tout le
weekend de Pâques avec des des cloches
géantes avec des animaux et toujours
avec des jeux d'indices et des cadeaux
évidemment chocolatés pour les enfants
ça et puis le printemps les vacances de
printemps en fait ils ne se passera
rarement des des choses dans les de les
lieux culturels le lieu patrimoniaux
dédié aux enfants et au public pour des
belles promenades et on va mettre
Dampierre avec des jolies mises en scène
de printanières puisque au printemps le
château et bien on ouvre les fenêtres en
étant on fait le lavage de printemps on
fait des grandes lessives donc il y aura
des draps qui vont sécher qui vont voler
au vent des nichoirs qui vont permettre
d'accueillir les mésanges etc donc tout
un tout un thème autour de ce printemps
et puis après dans les grosses
nouveautés un peu plus tard les belles
Dampierre là ont vraiment c'était une
première édition l'année dernière et là
on réunit
un bel ensemble historique de voitures
hypomobile et de voitures automobiles la
jonction le passage entre les deux mais
vraiment le des ancêtres automobiles et
les dernières voitures de carrosserie
Hippo mobile donc là on est vraiment sur
un beau montage avec les associations
locales autour de Rambouillet et puis je
vais un peu vite mais cet été art
contemporain dans le jardin de
l'anglaise il y aura des guinguettes au
mois de juin au mois de juillet parce
que évidemment faire connaître le
patrimoine c'est aussi pouvoir le vivre
et vivre une guinguette c'est danser
c'est boire un verre et une place de
chat une planche de charcuterie ou une
planche de fromage voilà on essaye de
vraiment faire vivre ce domaine c'est
vraiment notre volonté puis découvrir
son histoire il y a aussi des QR codes
qui ont été disposés sur il y a des QR
code côté disposés sur le parcours avec
valorisation de la biodiversité du
patrimoine et puis prochainement alors
là j'ai hâte parce que c'est des
problèmes techniques qui me bloquent
là-dessus mais normalement sur le site
internet les gens qui envie de découvrir
le château et bien pourront faire une
visite en m'accompagnant une visite
guidée immersive c'est une petite
nouveauté je pense que je reviendrai à
expliquer ça un peu plus tard quand ça
sortira vous serez vraiment curieux et
donc on fera une visite dans le château
et là bah voilà c'est une petite poème
technique qui nous font prendre du
retard mais ça va être sympa on peut
suivre l'actualité en tout cas sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran j'imagine qu'il y aura toujours
les classiques les balades en calèche en
Rosalie toujours possible les balades en
attelage tirés par Nomi américaines et
la nouveauté c'est que cette année le
propriétaire cet hiver a installé dans
une prairie humide dans une zone humide
pardon il a des Bleus Island parce que
vraiment pour leur promener un entretien
respectueux de l'environnement donc on a
début Island et au milieu de ces bailand
et bien il y a des biches qui viennent
et là même pas il farouchés par le
public on arrive il y a des bichons
c'est vraiment extraordinaire et puis
évidemment les rosalies les golfettent
les aires de jeux les aires de
pique-nique enfin vraiment voilà nous ce
qu'on veut c'est que le public Vienne
évidemment mais surtout pas un moment
une heure une heure ou une journée de
plaisir passez un bon moment sur place
alors pour venir au domaine juste des
questions pratique est-ce qu'il faut
prendre son billet à l'avance on peut
venir directement sur place tout était
possible nous on est vraiment très
ouvert donc du coup la billetterie en
ligne elle marche et fonctionne très
bien mais si au dernier moment pour
venir il y a toujours la possibilité de
l'habiller très sur place l'habiller
très en ligne l'avantage surtout pour
les locations d'attelage parce que c'est
là que les gens réserve alors soyez pas
surpris puisque je disais que le site
était en travaux et dès qu'on arrive
délabilletterie et bien en train
d'agrandir la billetterie on est en
train de construire un parc de
stationnement donc il y a un peu un
univers un peu de chantier mais on a
tout fait pour que le public puisse se
retrouver et puisse rentrer à la suite
ce domaine les prix d'entrée 8 euros 8
euros voilà 8 euros puis après il y a
toutes les déclinaisons sur les tarifs
réduits pour les Yvelinois je fais un
petit peu de pub pour le département
mais il y a le passe malin qui existe
qui donne tarif réduit et puis il y a
plein de tarifs réduits qui s'appliquent
en fonction des âges et des catégories
sociales bon après une balade dans le
domaine de Dampierre on pourra se rendre
du côté de trap samedi soir pour le
fest-noz je le rappelle qui a lieu du
côté de la Meurice la salle de la mairie
ce sera à 20h ce samedi c'est organisé
votre association Christian Étienne le
cercle celtique 16 aveugles votre
association le disait fêter l'an passé
50 ans le festo c'est toujours un
rendez-vous apprécié attendu des
trappistes et des Yvelines tout à fait
et dans la région il est très réputé
maintenant on a pris quand même de
l'ampleur et il est très attendu il y a
eu une coupure de 2 ans à cause des
événements du covid mais la reprise on
l'a fait pour les 50 ans du cercle
l'année dernière au mois de septembre et
un nouvel engouement
de se retrouver au faisceau de trappe
c'est un événement qui a pris aussi de
l'ampleur on l'imagine d'année en année
vous le dites aujourd'hui c'est l'un des
principaux en Île-de-France
en Île-de-France parce que la salle est
exceptionnelle pour ce genre de
manifestation et de plus on a toujours
essayé de l'innover dans dans la
prestation des groupes cette année nous
aurions un groupe international qui qui
n'avait un petit peu un peu partout en
Europe qui est Plantec et il a une
particularité c'est comme on dit la
culture bretonne évolue aussi la musique
bretonne évolue aussi et là il y aura
trois musiciens sur scène avec des
vidéos sur des paramètres projecteurs
sur des écrans à l'arrière et ces trois
dans ces trois musiciens il y a un DJ la
preuve que la musique bretonne est
entrée dans la modernité l'année
dernière à l'Eurovision il me semble que
c'est un groupe breton
représenté la France l'Eurovision et
pour les devises comprendre la langue
bretonne c'est pas facile alors pour
ceux qui connaissent pas justement la
culture bretonne lefest nose c'est
mettre en avant justement cette culture
Burton bretonne qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'un fest-nose c'est un ensemble de
choses en fait c'est la musique la danse
et puis c'est une chose qui était
classée au patrimoine immatériel de
l'Unesco parce que il y a cette
particularité que il y a seulement de
convivialité et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on voit toutes les
générations mélangées c'est pour tout le
monde
ah oui c'est ouvert à tout le monde il y
a aucun problème comme on dit il suffit
de rentrer dans la danse et on est pris
par le jeu et on se met à danser cet
événement ça se prépare sur plusieurs
mois imagine le dernier stand 2022
au mois de mars ça a toujours été au
mois de mars et c'est une programmation
qu'on prépare un an à l'avance alors
qu'est-ce qui est au menu vous avez
commencé à nous présenter un petit peu
la programmation un groupe international
qui sera l'affiche qu'est-ce qui est au
menu de plante avec notre groupe qui est
Coffe et puis nous avons aussi le bagad
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est
avec lequel nous faisons beaucoup de
prestations à l'heure actuelle un petit
peu partout dans la région et nous
aurons un couple de sonore traditionnel
qui sont deux anciens musiciens du Bagad
de Lann-Bihoué dont un pet solaire qui
est Jean-Paul Constantin et avec un
sonneur qui est dans l'association
depuis pas mal d'années maintenant avec
qui nous avons ouvert le premier
fest-noz qui est
qui est
un musicien hors pair vous attendez
combien de personnes la moyenne tourne
autour de 500 500 personnes et là c'est
complet où on peut encore des
possibilités il y a des réservations sur
et puis il y a la billetterie à l'entrée
de la Merise samedi soir il y a aussi
internet qui s'affiche pour un peu plus
d'informations le prix d'entrée de 10
euros et pour les groupes 10 personnes
ça fait 8 euros par personne j'ai déjà
fait participer à des fest-noz autour de
la table moi je me souviens dans mon
village en Essonne il y a quelques
années mais c'était il y a quelques
années déjà quand j'étais petit
mais d'ailleurs j'ai juste une petite
question à vous êtes président du Cercle
Celtique says aveugle je sais pas si je
le prononce pas qu'est-ce que ça
signifie les 7 vents alors il semblerait
que c'est tiré d'une vieille légende
bretonne qui dirait que quand les 7
vents se mettent à souffler c'est la
tempête qui se déchaîne
bien sûr en tout cas d'être venu
présenter le programme de ce hypnose qui
a lieu je le disais ce samedi à Trappes
à la salle de la mairie c'est à partir
de 20h d'autres idées de sortie aussi au
menu de ce weekend yvelinois avec vous
Céline on va commencer on le disait tout
à l'heure avec un rendez-vous autour du
chanteur de la légende Johnny Hallyday
oui 5 ans après sa mort on ne l'oublie
pas l'idole des jeunes vit toujours dans
le cœur de ses fans d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas si vous le saviez autour de la
table mais le fan club officiel du
chanteur est situé dans les Yvelines
depuis plus de 20 ans et c'est cette
fois-ci un voisin le Bretonneux que
plusieurs événements vont avoir lieu
autour de Johnny pendant une semaine on
écouter Rémi bouée président du fan club
du fan club depuis 20 ans il est à
l'origine du projet
[Musique]
cette exposition elle est assez
incroyable parce que d'abord elle est
vraiment inédite Patrick Deguine est
d'abord quelqu'un qui aimait Johnny
Hallyday qui faisait partie du fan club
et un jour Johnny a dit ok je veux bien
parce que c'est le fan club qui me
suivent sur deux tournées donc des
photos exclusives qu'on n'a jamais
explosé encore et pour la première fois
il y a plus de 50 clichés qui sont
exposés proposés aux vicinois
qu'il a accompagné pendant près de 20
ans de Johnny Hallyday dans toutes ces
sa dernière partie de carrière où il
avait vraiment un groupe rock'n'roll et
lui est à l'harmonica je pense un des
quatre cinq meilleurs vraiment au monde
[Musique]
il va présenter son propre spectacle
donc c'est pas des reprises de Johnny
mais évidemment il y a des super clin
d'oeil parce que sur scène il partageait
des morceaux comme Gabriel d'une manière
incroyable
vers 11h madame le Maire les officiels
entre guillemets et puis les les gens de
voisins plus les fans vont être réunis
pour pour l'inauguration officielle de
cette exposition je crois même qu'il y a
une association de la ville qui fait de
la danse country qui va venir danser sur
du johnny c'est extraordinaire on a
réuni une vingtaine d'arlers des
voitures américaines pour que le décor
soit à la hauteur évidemment un déjeuner
à l'extérieur avec dans le style
américain burger frites etc sous des
tentes ça va être sympa on va être 150 à
déjeuner
le fan club de Johnny c'était de son
vivant le lien entre lui et le public et
malheureusement depuis sa disparition on
a un devoir de de que cette légende
continue de vivre et on est là pour ça
[Musique]
et n'hésitez pas à prendre rapidement
vos places pour le concert les places
restantes se compte littéralement sur
les doigts d'une main un titre de Johnny
Hallyday qui vous vient à l'esprit moi
allumer le feu c'est le premier qui lui
à l'esprit Christian Étienne je t'aime
Gabriel Gabriel Régine
Omar en tout cas ça parle à toutes les
générations on peut le voir Johnny
Hallyday avec ce weekend spécial et même
une semaine spéciale à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux direction
Versailles maintenant Céline avec un
salon c'est le Versailles des créateurs
tout à fait ça se passera sur la place
du marché Notre-Dame samedi 25 mars de
10h à 19h le Versailles des créateurs
mais à l'honneur depuis 2016 l'artisanat
local et le fait main sur place vous
pouvez retrouver une soixantaine de
marques locales artisanales et
responsables ce sont essentiellement des
créateurs Versailles et bijoux
décoration épicerie fine ou encore des
livres il y en aura pour tous les goûts
des animations pour les enfants sont
également au programme une sortie
musicale du côté de Guyancourt direction
la batterie de Guyancourt samedi 25 mars
à 20h30 je vous propose le concert d'une
chanteuse Emily Loizeau écoutait un
extrait
la veine encore pour que le monde nous
sommes
[Musique]
se pourrait-il qu'un jour la beauté nous
rassemble et nous importe si oh
mais ta mort
Emilie Loiseau nous propose sur scène
son nouvel album
Icare une sorte de journal intime écrit
pendant le confinement la chanteuse
aussi entre chanson française et pop
rock elle sera accompagnée de lonie en
première partie du concert balade
mélancolique et folk sont au menu on
termine ses idées avec la civilité de
visiter de revisiter le Titanic Titanic
la folle traversait c'est une comédie
musicale portée par la compagnie les
moutons noirs ce sera samedi à 20h30 à
Lagrange de la Tremblay à Bois-d'Arcy
sur scène 9 comédiens et trois musiciens
l'accompagnie a réalisé un gros travail
d'écriture pour vous livrer un spectacle
divertissant leur objectif transformer
la tragédie du Titanic en une comédie
burlesque vous allez pouvoir embarquer à
bord du célèbre bateau et suivre les
histoires de personnages oubliés un
héritier qui cherche son lapin ou encore
un prêtre en pleine crise de foi par
exemple pensez par contre à réserver vos
places
désormais merci Céline pour toutes ces
idées j'ai oublié de vous demander
Christian Étienne il y a un dress code
pour venir au fest-noz samedi est-ce que
il faut en tenue traditionnelle bretonne
pas du tout pas du tout on vient comme
on est voilà
le porte dans les manifestations
culturelles mais non non il y avait
aucun souci venez comme vous êtes en
tout cas pour les téléspectateurs qui se
posent la question de comment ils vont
s'habiller ce weekend pour venir
peut-être au fest-nos pour venir aussi
du côté du domaine de Dampierre en
Yvelines mélissa sebir est là pour vous
aider à les styliste et modiste à
Richebourg dans les Yvelines à la fonder
sa propre marque elle la mode de Mélissa
et vous partage ses meilleurs conseils
pour savoir comment vous habiller au
quotidien ce soir elle vous donne des
astuces pour choisir les pièces
indémodable de votre garde-robe
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Mélissa sebir la
fondatrice de la mode de Mélissa et on
se retrouve aujourd'hui pour parler mode
je vais vous donner quelques conseils
pour avoir une penderie indémodable
[Musique]
parce que c'est important d'avoir un
dressing de plus en plus éthique je me
suis dit qu'il serait bien intéressant
de vous partager quelques conseils pour
que vous puissiez avoir des tenues ou en
tout cas des pièces indémodables que
vous allez donc garder sur du long terme
c'est beaucoup plus éthique alors voici
quelques conseils
le carreau le tartan le pied de poule
vraiment tous les motifs à base de
carreaux c'est vraiment quelque chose
que vous devez avoir impérativement dans
votre dressing si vous voulez acheter
moins mais mieux et de ce fait conserver
plus longtemps vos vêtements par exemple
ce trench en partant vous pourrez le
garder toute votre vie c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement indémodable
et c'est ça qui est intéressant en fait
et si vous voulez l'actualiser au bout
du jour il vous suffira de mettre une
ceinture de l'époque dans laquelle nous
serons dans quelques années ou en tout
cas de l'accessoiriser avec des
chaussures ou un sac et c'est comme ça
aussi que vous allez pouvoir le faire
perdurer dans le temps un motif hyper
tendance
c'est certain ça date des années 70 et
encore je pense qu'il y en avait même
avant le poids c'est vraiment un
indémodable que vous devez
impérativement avoir dans votre
garde-robe si vous voulez avoir des
pièces qui ne se démotent pas le motif
fleuri c'est quelque chose qu'on qui
traverse complètement le temps que ce
soit en plus en hiver au printemps en
été vous pouvez le porter toute l'année
et ça c'est plutôt bien donc que je vous
invite vraiment à miser sur des pièces
avec des carreaux des fleurs des pois ce
que je vous conseille vraiment pour
avoir une garde-robe qui va perdurer
dans le temps c'est de privilégier des
pièces plutôt simples qui ont une coupe
simple vous voyez par exemple ce
chemisier je l'ai cousu cette année mais
dans 10 ans on pourra avoir l'impression
qu'il vient seulement d'être cousu vous
voyez parce que justement il a une forme
simple il faut vraiment que vous misiez
sur des formes plutôt simples parce que
si vous prenez des vêtements qui ont des
attraits particuliers à l'instant T à
l'époque t dans laquelle vous l'avez
acheté ils vont plus vite passer de mode
et du coup ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué pour vous de les porter
ensuite donc vraiment miser sur la forme
simple d'un vêtement et aller chercher
l'originalité et l'intemporalité sur le
motif en conclusion je vous invite
vraiment à vous tourner vers des pièces
qui ont des coûts plutôt simple et avec
des motifs intemporels comme les
carreaux le Fleury ou encore les pois
pour que vous puissiez avoir une vraie
garde-robe éthique et éco-responsable
qui dure dans le temps
[Musique]
voilà de nouveaux conseils à retrouver
prochainement sur la TV 78 c'est bientôt
la fin de ce 7 8 mais avant de vous
laisser un dernier coup d'oeil par la
météo de demain
même condition météo même température
demain matin sur l'ensemble du
territoire yvelinois avec quelques
éclaircies il fera 11 degrés dans le
Nord et le Sud du département dans
l'après-midi prévoyez un temps qui vire
à l'orage avec quelques averses côté
température il fera 13 degrés à
Rambouillet 14 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdan et ce vendredi 24
mars nous fêterons les quatre innées
alors Céline quels sont les prévisions
météo pour ce week-end
alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous c'est Thomas Fletcher je suis là
pour vous présenter la météo de vos
weekends beaucoup de motivation avant de
commencer si vous avez des réclamations
à faire sur mes prévisions
météorologiques n'hésitez pas à me
contacter sur l'adresse mail qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pendant
cette météo nous irons à votre rencontre
à la rencontre des yvelinois et donc
c'est parti alors quoi de beau ce
week-end samedi sachez qu'à titre
d'information c'est la journée de la
procrastination donc pour moi flemme
c'est ma première on prend notre temps
donc je vous laisse profiter de nos
Yvelines
voilà
voilà dimanche il va pleuvoir toute la
journée dans les Yvelines dans la
matinée à Rambouillet il fera 8 degrés
vers ou dans il fera plus 7 degrés donc
pas non plus des grosses températures de
la matinée c'est pas moi qui décide dans
l'après-midi nous atteindrons les 10
degrés sur Versailles et Rambouillet
toujours de la pluie ça rime il nous
faut de l'eau pour pour nos petits pots
et nous allons maintenant aller voir
vous je dis bien vous les Yvelinois il y
a un gros changement ce week-end c'est
le changement d'heure nous allons voir
ça avec vous ce que vous en pensez et
s'il y a des montres à régler alors
est-ce que vous savez que du coup ce
weekend c'est changement d'heure je
savais pas et ben ça fait plaisir de
vous la prendre
plus tard
on avance on recule alors vous me posez
trop de questions
c'est pas réfléchi
non non non non non non non
on va dormir pareil
[Musique]
on verra bien au moment où je me couche
à 7h25 exactement le réveil donc là ce
sera 6h25 non ça sera 7h25 8h25 non ça
sera 7h25 juste 7h25
madame cette interview est fatiguante
[Rires]
alors quoi de beau
il va être proposé désormais chaque
jeudi par Thomas Fletcher bonsoir Thomas
bonsoir Thomas qui est habituellement
monteur à TV 78 mais qui s'est
reconversé en Mister météo il a mis son
beau Costa
nuageux voilà le temps peut-être nuageux
ce week-end en tout cas on a pu voir ce
qu'il sera ce qu'il se dont il sera
question voilà j'en perd mes mots parce
que j'ai assez rigolé sur votre
chronique mais du coup j'ai pas compris
il sera dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche c'est à quel moment qu'on
change d'heure c'est dimanche soir ouais
à 2h je crois que samedi
3h du matin directement
depuis le début et juste le principe en
quelques secondes c'est de présenter la
météo vous allez à la rencontre des
yvelinois aussi c'est ça d'avoir des
vrais retours de savoir ce qu'ils font
de beau le week-end et puis
et puis voir s'il y a de la météo qui va
avec quoi on a devoir la suite petite
réaction Régine Céline sur cette
nouvelle chronique mais j'attends le
costume soleil
sur TV 78 voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité et on se
retrouve dès lundi pour une nouvelle
édition d'ici là passez un excellent
weekend sur TV 78
[Musique]